[موسيقى]
خفوت شعاع الشمس بحيث اننا نشاهد الشمس
مثل البدر بدون شعاع هذا يدل على كثافه
الغبار وهذا يصير بول الصيف كانه ثريا
امور بعنيه القيض والدوائر المحيطه حوالين
البدر هذا يدل على غزاره الرطوبه وهذا
يكون في عز القير ذبحت وجمره الجيض الجوزه
الملزم التليبين وزرقه وجه السماء هذا يدل
على شده البروده وهذا يكون في عز الشتاء
المربعانيه والشغل هكذا كان اهالينا
يعرفون الاجواء عن طريق الظواهر المشاهده
فهم يهتدون بهذه العلامات كهتداء العمياني
في الطريق وعلامات وبالنجم هم يهتدون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومن الظواهر الطبيعيه التي تحدث في اول
الصيف كحال ايامنا هذه هو الغبار والغبار
ينقسم الى قسمين غبار عابر وغبار دائم
العابر هو الغبار الذي ينتقل من منطقه الى
منطقه تاليه او الغبار السابق للحالات
المطريه والمصاحب للرياح الهابطه والغبار
الدائم هو الغبار اللصيق على وجه السماء
والذي يستمر لمده ثلاثه شهور تقريبا يحصل
على اليمن وجنوب السعوديه نواحي المناطق
التهاميه على جازان كواد لا يزل له عثار
وجاري لا يشق له غبار
[موسيقى]